meilleur moment de l'année c'est quand
cyril a finalement cet effet dessus
personne ne le sait mais il avait une
envie pressante
on sait à quel point elle est mal à se
retenir y avait il est tout à fait pnd
en sept ans le situe sans rigoler la dtn
castaldi mais ça nous a traumatisés
il a bu mois d'été où il a les tétons
les plus longs de loi de l'histoire bon
car ils étaient pas moins que pour
l'honneur
c'est le patron on accepte on a souvent
tu monte pas au mieux le fameux deux
tués
ça y est c'est ses chocolats savage et
pas de dettes
alors on chronic préféré c'est je pense
que c'est je pense que c'est des élèves
modèles première de la classe
jamais un défaut jamais une mèche qui
dépasse de profits toujours lisse
apparemment pas se débarrasser
alors venez rire vous aimez
alors chers vérité un peu là nagui de
ces huttes entre trouve à toutes les
sauces et c'est pas toi que je vais
apprendre qu'une boulette
quand on la trouve dans plusieurs choses
là on peut difficilement avaler mais y'a
un truc à donges est simplement
incontestablement matthieu delormeau il
la ramène toujours c'est rarement dedans
c'est très bruyant où c'est très agaçant
et au final c'est voilà c'est ça n'a pas
d'intérêt
on a été pressé non si j'aime bien
qu'avant son capital était attendue sera
[Applaudissements]
tu peux tu dois savoir si tu viens non
mais je suis là je suis pas loin mais
c'est la carmagnole allez allez
attention c'est parti avec le
[Musique]
alors
cependant les la danse ballet un petit
peu en corse et ensuite je veux être à
gauche à droite au nord sud elle
souhaite un peu un peu sur ma mère en
bretagne un peu chez des copains en sus
d'un peu peut-être pas trop en europe
mais elle souhaite et si oui normalement
oui sauf accident ou du bois est atone
et attend quoi pour les prochaines
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour l'année quoi
je serais les dix en france combat bien
séparer de france avec une très très
belle année sur l invention m'ont bien
aux dépens cette année on sait on s'est
éclaté je pense qu'on sait on encore
renforcer la complicité dans l'équipe
donc c'est une belle année pour moi moi
je me régale moi j'ai vous connaissez si
vous aviez un super pouvoir vous castany
serez croirait voir dans votre pensée ah
oui mais vraiment pas le vrai cyril
bonne demande et moi celui qui dit par
exemple c'est pas mon style ouais là
celui qui dit vous et beaucoup de talent
ah ouais ouais ouais bon c'est vrai que
dans votre tête mais c'est vraiment
quand il dit qu'il nous a dit voilà on
ne sait pas ce que les parents ne sais
pas tous les invités sont ses préférées
oui c'est ça du tout dans nos six mois
les procès là
tu sais qu'on doit s'affronter je sais
que tu as peur c'est que tu roules sans
cesse le moment où je vais devoir
remonter sur le ring avec corps et là
évidemment ce sera ce sera une boucherie
de lecelles problème mais je vais
m'occuper de lui pendant la pub j'ai
encore lui met une thalasso